hey guys it's Jonah here if having bad
knees is your excuse for not exercising
what the truth is that should not stop
you from doing lower body movements I'm
gonna share with you the do's and don'ts
when it comes to working out with bad
knees and how these exercises can help
to prevent and reduce injuries now
before we get started if you haven't yet
subscribed to my YouTube channel be sure
to do so ok and turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new
workout video recipe or fitness tip
avoid deep squats deep squats are great
to work on your legs and glutes if done
properly however if you suffer from bad
knees
this can cause further pain because it
involves an extreme bending motion and
it can put high amounts of stress on
your knee joints if you don't perform
deep squats properly over time incorrect
form can also cause a knee and back
injuries
hence it is extremely important to check
your posture when exercising perform
partial squats instead start in a
neutral position with both legs
shoulder-width apart and toes pointed
forward only squat as low as 45 degrees
without going too deep this partial
movement will not cause excessive stress
on your knees eventually as you recover
or experience less pain on your knees
then you can slowly squat
deeper avoid lunges if done properly
lunges are a great functional workout as
it strengthens your legs hips and core
muscles although this might seem like a
really simple move lunges can be
difficult to perform especially if your
knees are weak or if you are recovering
from knee injuries this movement
requires a good amount of stabilization
on your legs and core hence it can place
lots of stress on your knees if they are
weak start by performing bridging
instead bridging targets and strengthens
the glutes hamstrings hips core and
lower back muscles without stressing out
the knees lie on your back with your
knees bent and arms by your sides push
your heels into the floor squeeze the
butt and lift your hips off the floor
until your shoulders hips
and these are in a straight line hold
for about two to three counts then
slowly lower the hips and repeat because
you're performing the movement while
lying down this will not place much
stress on your knee joints but at the
same time you're strengthening your
lower body muscles avoid kicking bent
knees are highly strained when you snap
your leg to kick when you kick with high
impact and at a fast pace that sudden
jerk can be really tough on your joints
and this can put greater stress on your
knees if you keep on kicking with a Rome
technique over time you can overuse the
muscles around your knees causing
chronic knee injury perform side leg
raises this exercise can help strengthen
your thigh muscles and shape your legs
stand shoulder width apart with toes
pointed forward as you brace your core
extend and lift one leg out to the side
in a fully controlled manner squeeze the
glutes and thighs right at the top and
repeat on the opposite leg avoid fast or
jerky movements remember to always
engage your core avoid jumping high
impact exercises such as jumping can
only worsen your knee pain high impact
movements shock your knee joints and
place lots of stress on the knees when
you land
jumping places a force of two to three
times your body weight across your knees
which can increase the potential for
injury if you have knee problems you
should avoid jumps that require a very
deep knee bend or could torque than knee
on landing perform step ups low impact
activities such as step ups is more
suitable and can be just as effective
you can use a stepper staircase box or
even a chair to do step ups this
movement will not create as much stress
on your knees but you're still able to
get a good sweaty cardio workout from it
avoid high knee jumps again exercises
that involve jumping like high knee
jumps which focus on increasing muscle
power can be tough on the knee joints
especially when landing the high impact
movement of this exercise and repeating
it at a very fast pace may cause you to
compromise on proper form which can put
your knees at
higher risk of injuries that gentle and
perform knee lifts instead this exercise
works on your entire lower body while
challenging your balance at the same
time so stand tall with your feet
shoulder-width apart brace your core and
slowly raise one knee upward to meet
your hands at a 90 degree angle lower
and change sides as you raise your leg
be sure to engage your core to keep your
balance and feel the contraction on your
lower abs a void treadmill running
weather outdoors or on a treadmill is
also a high-impact exercise that creates
a great deal of stress on your knees
running can stress the knee with up to 8
times the force of walking so if you
have a pre-existing knee damage or if
you're extremely overweight running may
not be the best option for you perform
elliptical instead the elliptical
machine mimics the motion of running -
at the high impact making it a far
better and safer choice when you have
knee pain this is a low impact cardio
workout that uses both the legs and arms
for power the circular movement helps
provide an excellent new range of motion
hip flexion and extension and because
you're fully supported by the machine it
does not strain your ankle and knee
joints and can be safely performed even
with an inflamed knee so stop doing
exercises that can hurt and worsen your
weak or inflamed knees and start
performing the right and safe exercises
that can actually help you to strengthen
your legs and knees to prevent any
future injuries or stiffness and to
perform each exercise for 15 to 20
repetitions and a total of 2 to 3 sets
be sure to like this video share down
with someone who might be having bad
knees and do also check out more workout
videos and fitness tips on my channel
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
and get notified when I upload new
videos every week all the best